we get future like a seven if you just
read Lana bro
so future is able to do some you know
some what is that fair come on that's
not fair karma it's good
all right so whoever got onto John Wall
Jersey with the DC head and are those
white ball mains we got to stop the
white jeans you look like a painter bro
but you're trash you get a zero drag
it's the tip of this ovo sweat suit they
have like a velour one that I was trying
to get so hey Drake and he got the grand
pomp here so everybody loves Drake I'm
gonna get rid of ten because that's the
homies that I'm gonna give easier tank
if you got the curl
i'ma get Dre I know about that bracelet
I'll give him all the Tendo and not
doing too much they keep their regular I
don't feel about Busta Rhymes outfit I
love bus rides my friend you got to get
like a four did you watch me shower just
too much and he got chains on me I'm not
[ __ ] with the chains big eyes changed
in 2015 bro he's like your roots and
he's saluting what are you saluting our
girls face you're like an eight because
that jacket is crazy cold meth gets a 10
because he brought us how high ODB gets
a thirty kids in the cut cut not really
worried about this picture you god gets
to zero that I don't like it so long but
she was trashed
overall it was like a seven eight I
don't see where those who actually moved
my 7206 is that a corsage oh no doctor I
got a better picture of Fresh Prince
today
look either got his goddamned mind will
spit was fly bro that's tragedy he never
went out again tit
I like Paul that's a big ass t-shirt
though I was like a six TV Johnny gets a
zero because that big ugly ass soldier
boy walk all the kill Calle yeah I love
kill Kanye bro the leather pants leather
shirt kiyah he was onto some [ __ ] bro
it's confidence he spewing confidence
row and he was watching the grown
robbery was aware jeev Archie before
Calais or good Vinci as they like to
call it a mental change blame him it's a
shame
Justin Bieber is a man ten bro it's a
ten look at that led dinners haircut on
him fly